actors after constantly ponder their
next moves what if a role turns out to
be nothing like they thought can they
speak openly about regret if they do
will they ever work again the following
TV actors regretted some aspect of their
work a poorly shot scene a show they
wish had gone differently a job they
wouldn't take if they had to do it over
again and admitted their disappointment
later on in the weeds
mary-louise Parker has filmed a number
of steamy scenes in a long career and
more than one in her role as Nancy
Botwin on Showtime's weeds work for me
so far but for one 2008 episode Parker
shot a revealing bathtub scene we can't
show here that she later wished she
could take back
she told more magazine I forward the
director about it and now I'm bitter I
wish I hadn't done that I was goaded
into it she later clarified that the
fight was really just a creative
discussion and that she's totally
comfortable being in a birthday suit on
camera and off saying I was talking
about that scene as an example of
something I didn't love as much when I
saw it dark turn
Devon gummersall is best known for
playing Brian Krakow the big head Angela
chase obsessed nerd on the short-lived
90s drama my so-called life finally an
erection from actual physical contact
domicile would go on to portray Stevie
Wolcott on Mad Men but before he was
Peggy Olson's blind date he played a
very bad dude named Zack on the Keri
Russell led WB cereal Felicity at the
time a gummersall was into the role
because it was such a departure from
previous characters in retrospect he
later told cosmopolitan he sees it as a
mistake I loved being on the show but in
the end I realized that it was sort of a
mistake to do that kind of storyline I
would have much rather been on the show
more long-term and and something that
didn't have to end in such a bad way
unhealthy Minds Mandy Patinkin who
played agent Jason Gideon on CBS's
Criminal Minds for two seasons quit the
procedure will in 2007 after not
attending a table read Patinkin later
said he regretted making the decision to
do the show in the first place
due to its graphic and violent nature
Patinkin told New York Magazine in 2012
it was very destructive to my soul and
my personality Patinkin who now plays
Saul on Showtime's homeland explained
what he sees as the difference between
the two shows of homeland which
self isn't without violence Patinkin
said it asks why there's a need for
violence in the first place
friends like these for five episodes in
1999 a friend saw the addition of
jeanine played by model elle macpherson
who moved into Joey's apartment and
briefly became his love interest after
Chandler moved across the hall to live
with Monica most actors would have
killed to extend their arc on the wildly
popular show / McPherson turned down the
opportunity saying that had she known
the show would have had such staying
power she wouldn't have taken the job in
the first place
if I'd known how important it was in the
u.s. or how long it would be on TV and
may not have chosen to do it well the
show proved Korea making for
Macpherson's cast mates she spent the
last 20 years reminding people she had a
career before and after Jeanine OC
overkill Mischa Barton played Marissa
Cooper on Fox's EOC a drama about
beautiful wealthy teens that ran for
four seasons
although Cooper was written off in a car
accident in the show at the end of
season three since leaving the show
Barton has been open about her regrets
telling the UK's Metro in 2014 it's
something I came so close to not doing
it had a really great thing with film
people say be grateful for what you have
but it's certainly not the kind of thing
I was expecting it to be the OSI plunge
to all of its young stars into the
spotlight which Barton particularly
presented I just like to be seen for the
hard-working actress that I am enough
for a bunch of extraneous press
community feud after being out of the
entertainment spotlight for years Chevy
Chase returned to television in 2009 as
part of NBC's community in 2013 joined
the critically lauded but permanently
rating staff shows for season chase left
calling his decision to join the cast a
big mistake citing the exhaustion of
doing long television hours and calling
sitcoms quotes the lowest form of
television chase and the show's creator
Dan Harmon were also engaged in a
well-documented feud okay thanks for
coming thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Applause]
you